In California, they did something really sneaky.
They put this curriculum into the anti-bullying curriculum.
So usually you would think this would go into the sex ed curriculum,
which parents are allowed to opt out of,
but they put it into the anti-bullying curriculum under the pretext that you
couldn't possibly police bullying,
unless you taught every child that only they know their true gender.
And of course we know that's nonsense because you,
you can absolutely police bullying and should police bullying against sexual
minorities and every other student,
without introducing everybody to a,
to a false ideology.
[Inaudible].
The five is about the schools.
And I think this is kind of fascinating because we've sort of just watched
intellectual rot run across all of our schools. And you,
you just have to kind of go with whatever the thing of the day is.
Um, how much of this is just sort of being taught at public schools.
Do you think, I know it depends what state you're in,
but here we are both in Cali.
So in California, right? It's very extreme in this state.
So it, gender identity, education is something you can't opt out of.
It begins in kindergarten and it's really extreme. We start by teaching,
you know, five-year-olds that, whatever, however, they were born,
a doctor just made a guess and only they know their true gender and this doesn't
push kids to transition necessarily.
But what it does do is the moment these young girls in particular hit
adolescence. They go through a period where they hate their own bodies.
They feel ugly. This is something nearly every woman will, can attest to, um,
the,
the solution readily leaps to mind because it's something they've learned about
for years. And it's that, Oh my gosh,
I know why I'm so uncomfortable in my body.
It's because I'm supposed to be a boy.
Were you able to figure out at all how these bad ideas get so
influential at all the schools seemingly all the schools,
at least in California, but we, but New York too, and, and all over the country,
just how infectious the ideas are.
Right?
So I was a little bit because I was able to get a lot of documents out of the
California teachers association, concerned teachers send them, sent them to be,
uh, sent them to me. And, um, there are,
there's really no division in California between the activists and the teachers,
activists are not only training the teachers. They are, um,
providing all the curriculum for, you know, um,
gender identity and sexual orientation education.
So it's coming from very extreme sources and in teachers who are a little
uncomfortable about it are completely intimidated into silence.
So when you say that at five years old, they're, they're taught this, um,
for the average parent that might go into that school and say, well,
I don't want my child hearing that at five years old, which no, five-year-old,
it has nothing to do with even what's true or not.
No five-year-old can comprehend this stuff that, that in effect,
that person is going to be blacklisted.
And God only knows what they'll do to the poor kid.
That that's right. You can't because in California,
they did something really sneaky.
They put this curriculum into the anti-bullying curriculum.
So usually you would think this would go into the sex ed curriculum,
which parents are allowed to opt out of,
but they put it into the anti-bullying curriculum under the pretext that you
couldn't possibly police bullying,
unless you taught every child that only they know their true gender.
And of course we know that's nonsense because you,
you can absolutely police bullying and should police bullying against sexual
minorities and every other student,
without introducing everybody to a,
to a false ideology.
Do you have any numbers on what percentage of the public school teachers like
actually buy it versus who's just going along.
I guess that would be hard to quantify.
It's very hard. Public school teachers are terrified. I have,
I spoke to one teacher who posted something on social media was very tame.
She said, I don't know, this seems to be confusing.
A lot of kids at my school effectively. And she was suspended immediately,
and this was on her private, um, Facebook page. So, um,
teachers are very, very afraid. Yeah.
So the next chapter is the moms and dads, which speaking of very, very afraid,
it seems like a lot of the moms and dads are too.
Yeah. They're afraid. They're afraid to lose custody. And these are, you know,
the parents who call me are overwhelmingly political Progressive's they are
proud allies. They've always been allies, but, um, the,
their only sort of hesitation is problem is they think, gosh,
this came out of nowhere. I mean,
I supported her when she said that she was a lesbian,
but now she's saying she's a boy and she wants to have her breasts removed.
I mean, I'm not sure that's right for her. And isn't, couldn't she regret it.
These are the most sort of obvious questions.
There's nothing hateful about these questions.
But today these parents are treated like bigots, they're isolated,
their friends drop them,
and very often friends will go behind their backs to send their daughters
encouragement by way of a binder that one of those compression garments or
otherwise, you know, castigate them for, for, for bigotry. Allegedly.
What did this teach you maybe, or you're a parent yourself. I mean,
did this teach you anything about parenting in general and,
and setting rules and being honest and the rest of it?
Sure.
I think one thing it taught me was really how much we've
over relied on experts.
These so-called experts who show up and claim to know more than we do
about our kids that we have spent. I don't know,
hundreds of thousands of hours raising. And I, and I think that, um,
I think that trusting your own instincts about what's right for your daughter.
I mean, if you, in many cases, parents will call me and they,
it just doesn't sit right with them,
but they are being pressured by the mental health establishment or doctors to
immediately agree with their daughter and,
and fast tracker to irreversible consequences that she's likely to
regret.
So since you said the P word Progressive's,
do you sense that there is a connection between sort of being
politically progressive and that he would end up in a situation like this,
that you sort of just, yes, everything goes all the time.
There is nothing that's really true per se,
and everything is sort of how you feel that this was the obvious outcome of it
in a weird way.
Well, I think Mike,
my take is that the reason so many progressive families have,
have fallen into this and let me say conservative families have as well.
But the reason it's,
it does seem to me majority progressive families is because they were less
skeptical of the culture. Um,
conservatives have known for a long time that social a social worker or a
psychologist might not, um, treat their values with respect,
but liberals were genuinely taken aback and completely caught off guard because
they thought, wait a second, I've been an ally my entire life.
This isn't about that. It's about the mental health of my daughter.
She's got anxiety, depression,
shouldn't we look at those things first and they were really assuming good faith
on behalf of, um, you know, frankly activists posing as doctors.
Yeah. And we've just,
it seems to me that that unfortunately for a lot of the liberals, and I think,
you know, a little bit about my story, you know, for a lot of liberals,
until something like this hits them, they think that there's,
there's nothing wrong there that, that it's just like, Oh, anything goes,
and then next thing you know,
they're confronted with this and then they feel a little bit different.
That's right. They,
they describe themselves now overwhelmingly as politically homeless.
And it's not because they feel conservative. Um, it's because they,
they are really horrified that by the assault on their families. I mean, that,
that, that all of these medical,
these mental health professionals and teachers would go behind their backs to
encourage their children to do something that they think is harmful to them is,
is so stunning to them. And it really,
it does make them really uncomfortable with, with progressive politics.
Yeah. So did you have a sense,
or do you have a sense that conservative parents have some better mechanisms to
fight this either by standing up to the school or maybe dealing with the child a
little bit differently or whatever it might be?
Yeah, it's interesting.
I think conservative parents were tended to be and should
be more skeptical of the culture.
They were more skeptical of the social workers and psychologists who claimed to
know so much about their parents, but they also look their, you know, their,
their default is that, what do you mean? You're suddenly a boy see,
sometimes progressive parents were afraid to say that because they don't want to
be big at it, but a conservative parent is,
might be more comfortable just saying, what do you mean? You've been a girl,
your whole life. You're a girl. I mean, just because you want a short haircut,
doesn't suddenly make you a boy.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about women's issues
instead of nonstop yelling, check, checkout our women's issues playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.